le feu vert a été donné ce mardi 30
novembre vingt mois après le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines va
de nouveau accueillir une compétition
sportive le septième grand prix de
vélizy sera programmé ce dimanche 5
décembre et réunira 150 sportifs c'est
une fierté c'est de redémarrer de
redémarrer les compétitions de
redémarrer les compétitions hivernales
pour pour les coureurs pour les
organisateurs pour les clubs franciliens
et c'est un signe très positif de que de
que de pouvoir donc
proposer du cyclisme pour tous après
avoir été transformés en méga centres de
vaccination en mars 2021 l'air centrale
est disponible depuis fin octobre
aujourd'hui plus de 600 vaccination sont
effectués quotidiennement dans les
coursives et non pas au centre de la
structure ce qui permet la cohabitation
vous le voyez derrière moi ce sont les
activités sportives et quotidienne du
vélodrome nationale qui ont repris le
cours de leur existence est en mode
événement donc ce soit un événement
culturel ou un événement sportif on
aménage au module l'art centrale pour
pour la configuration de l'événement en
question donc donc tout peut cohabiter à
l'heure actuelle plusieurs
manifestations sportives sont déjà
programmés pour les prochaines semaines
la structure accueillera notamment des
courses cyclistes régional en janvier
février si la situation sanitaire le
permis